[Music]
all right let's go to nicole in orlando
hey nicole what's going on how are we
doing
good how are you outstanding what are
you doing
i am um so i have a question
um my in-laws and i have a great
relationship we go golfing we go
shopping i mean why do you golf can i
ask you that why do you go i'm in
orlando so i think that's what you have
to do no golf is the worst
here's the thing the only thing worse
than golfing is cat people but and i
just realized that you're not a fat
person so are you a dog person
yes i am all right that's redeeming
quality i'm back all right so you can
golf as long as you've got a dog with
you okay so your golf i just lost half
the internet by the way
it was awesome so all right so you golf
with them you shop with them
right we have a great relationship i
just feel like my husband and myself
have a very surface level relationship
with them
you know they don't understand like any
hardships that we're going through or we
don't understand any hardships they're
going through
and in return we kind of live in this
like blissful optimism
life and it's just not it's just not
real life it sounds so good for uh an
in-law relationship
[Applause]
okay but then in return i am you know
going through hard things with my
parents and they're so supportive and i
just know that my husband's like longing
for this real relationship with his
parents ah there we go
you know it's just kind of hard he's
seen
he's seen how well my parents might
operate and then
but he says this is the way it's always
been with his parents they've never had
this open dialogue or communication
so he's how long have you been married
three years three years so in three
years and you all dated a couple years
before that probably
yeah okay so he's getting a ringside
seat to another way
families operate
correct and he loves what he's seeing
good for you guys man that's incredible
what a testament to you and your and
your folks that's rad
and so
do you want this relationship like do
you have this dreams of calling your
mother-in-law and just
saying you're not going to believe what
happened at work today so and so so
good-looking but and then in her going i
know you do you want that or are you
more longing for him
i'm
i just want it to be something that i
understand the basic parts of our
relationship like
well like two examples his his father
went in to the hospital for a few days
and we didn't even know until he came
out of the hospital
that sounds like my face
and i hope my family's listening that's
exactly how my family worked
yes and then um
you know we're going through ivf to get
pregnant and his mother just keeps
asking us if we want kids so it's like
well
we do yeah yeah
you know
so have you have you ever sat down and
let me back out
so
number one good for you
most people that i talk to either on
this show or off the show especially off
the show want to distance themselves
from their mother-in-law like just just
want to back out of this thing
completely or their father or whatever
um i have personally lived
the
what do you mean such and such uncles in
the hospital i called my uncle the other
day and he's like yeah my heart whatever
i'm doing better and i was like you're
what i wouldn't you know i had no idea
right so
and then i complain about it and then i
get like a text right my like somebody
in my family will text me and say just
want you to know that uncle whoever is
probably
not gonna you know it's that kind of
thing so right some of it is
a
some of it is a hard reality that some
people in our lives love us
the best they can by not telling us
things they don't want to bring us down
and they want to don't want to burden us
and no matter
how often i've said please let me know
so i can write you a letter so i can
call so i can pray for you so i can make
jokes at your expense whatever
please let me know their first instinct
when something goes wrong is
i don't want to bother anybody and
right
it drives me crazy but it is what it is
the other stuff
here's what i think
i think um just like your
husband didn't have a picture of what
this could look like
until he got to see it in action
my guess is your in-laws are very
similar they don't know what it's like
to sit down and have a
friend relationship or a deeply
connected family relationship no one's
ever shown them that
have you ever sat down and called your
mother-in-law and said hey i'd love to
just talk to you about what we're going
through and ask your opinion have you
ever experienced this have you do you
know anybody's experience and open up on
your side too
here's the horrors of ivf here's the how
much we want kids here's how expensive
it is here's how every doctor
appointment we're just our hearts are
beating fast and we're holding we're
clenching our fists
and open up to her in that way have you
ever tried that
no because i don't know if it's my place
to just try to bring this family out of
their shell and
my husband's just like it's the way it's
always been it's the way it's going to
be
okay so perfect perfect i don't know so
i wouldn't look at it as quote unquote
your responsibility
your responsibility is not to change
other people your responsibility is to
be true to nicole
and being true to nicole is you want
people in your life that are going to
walk alongside you and that you are
going to walk alongside
and the way we do that is not by oh i
don't know if they won if that one i'm
gonna just be true to myself
and i'm gonna open up and go first and
even if it means hey i know i'm your
daughter-in-law and this is weird but i
need someone to talk to about this and
i'm gonna model what this looks like and
if they abuse it
if you get a call in two weeks
and they have abused your boundaries you
tell them i don't wanna i can't stand it
people are like oh do you want kids you
want kids those questions are so hurtful
and then next week they call and say hey
do you want kids you have learned
i that's not a safe relationship for me
but you're you you are holding back
parts of you because like i don't know
if it's my place
and what that leads to is secrets and
secrets lead to resentment and
resentment leads to well screw you screw
you i'm doing my own christmas all right
that's no way to live and i
wholeheartedly reject with all of my
heart the quote it's always been that
way
okay i wholeheartedly reject it now i
may go all in and realize they're not
gonna
they have no interest or no skills in
changing that's fine
but i reject that's the way that's
always been
yeah that's how family trauma stays
family trauma that's how people grow up
and what will happen is your husband
will recreate this with y'all's kids
that's what i'm worried about yes so you
go first that's what the word
vulnerability means it means i could get
hurt in this deal but i'm gonna go
anyway all of this is a risk but i want
to model what this looks like and it is
not your responsibility to change them
it's just your responsibility to be
fully nicole everywhere
that makes sense
yeah and god almighty here's the thing
nicole i want you to leave your email
with kelly and i'm gonna send you a
hundred dollars every time i say the
words
does that make sense now i'm not
actually gonna pay you but i'm just
gonna say it out loud in my head i'm
gonna keep it running total i'll
probably never send you any money but
i've got to stop saying does that make
sense cause that's ridiculous but does
that make sense
yes okay good there's 100 100 bucks so
what what's the takeaway today what are
you gonna do
i'm just gonna
start
living my
life with the relationship i want them
to have with me which is just starting
to talk about this stuff and not being
scared to talk about it yes and
challenge your husband what's your
husband's name give me a fake name let's
call him billy
okay his name hope it's not his name
that'd been such a great guess not okay
so you're like i would never have
married a billy um all right so billy
i want him to start practicing the
relationship he would love to have with
him
right my son recently came and said hey
dad
i need to talk to you about something
and dude i'm smiling right now thinking
about it it brought me so much joy that
he trusted me enough to have that
conversation i always am i'm not scared
to have any conversation ever with
anybody but even i've been like i don't
know how to lean into this one but
it was such a gift and it opened up a
whole new thing
your husband may have the keys to unlock
your parents relationship and there's
just been this weird dance for so long
he can free everybody it'd be incredible
so tell him you all sit down and say hey
what would we want to talk about with
our in-laws
what would we want to talk about what do
you want to know from your dad do you
have some questions about hey what was
it like when you and mom were trying to
have kids
and were you nervous were you scared
give dad an opportunity to open up to
some of those things hey dad we just
talk about sports and weather
i was wondering what it's like to be
married to somebody who's trying to get
pregnant like walk me through that all
right dad can i ask your advice on this
money question or this
whatever quit
have your husband lean in and it can be
weird and awkward and his dad could be
like i don't want to talk about that son
or i'm going to give you one word but at
least he's going for it and we're not
just living in this i don't know i don't
know i don't want to stop my job it's
not i'm going first
so cool what a great question nicole hey
and blessings to you and your ivf
journey i know that is a nightmare for
folks and so we are rooting for you here
with the john doloni gang